[Music]
[Music]
alright here we go guys I got a Peterson
I got a Shapiro I got a Weinstein I got
a Reuben I feel I should go to you first
because using the Canadian yeah that's I
saw that movie was pretty bad
alright you're you're on real time
tonight and I thought that it's an
interesting little piece of all of this
because we're sort of all out of the
mainstream but we kind of dance in there
every now and again you probably dance
in there a little more than the rest of
us
you're gonna smack around Marv tonight
or what you know I think that it'll
probably be pretty pretty cordial I mean
I think that Marv is secretly one of us
now maybe I'm wrong but I think I think
that Marv is tired of the I mean his
show was called politically incorrect I
mean I think that he is tired of the
identity politics I think he's tired of
the intersectional nonsense I think that
he wants to have some open conversations
I just think that he is he's tied
politically the left so I'll be
interested to see how much of that he
goes after you know how much Trump talk
there is which I find utterly
uninteresting is that are and how much
of them will be about kind of broader
issues of freedom of speech and and
civility and having decent conversations
I think that he's on the right side of
those issues I mean I've played him on
my show right and I disagreed him on
everything politically but I play clips
of him on my show specifically on those
issues and him cracking the whip on
people on the identity politics nonsense
and I think we're on the same page there
well if he wants to be an effective
advocate for the left he should lead the
March and dissociating the moderate left
from the radical unreasonable left
someone's got to do it because the
strategy that they're abiding by right
now is pretty damn self-destructive and
he's in a good position to do that and I
think he's motivated to do it because he
is a free speech guy being a comedian
and everything
it's risky I think I think you take your
life in your hands if you're the leftist
she says that right now if you're the
person on the Left who does this I mean
you didn't survived but you but that's
I'm retired from the left that's right
you know so you you found it you found a
bunch of new friends right I mean that's
that's really what what people have to
understand is that when you when you
take these positions yes there gonna be
a lot of people who decide that you are
Satan but there's gonna be a whole lot
of people who are your new friends who
are ready to have these conversations
which is why you know again this sort of
IDW determinant that Eric coined is so
fascinating because everyone disagrees
with everyone about nearly everything in
this group but because we don't want to
shut down the conversation it's created
this whole audience for every one of us
like each one of us our audiences in
creased tremendously just by being part
of conversations with one another so
that's that's it to me what is it you
guys think about us and this wider what
I do just the awesomeness of the
amazingness and all that but like but
like minded people we just happen to be
the examples that are sitting here that
it is for all the differences that we've
talked about on gay marriage and
abortion and death penalty and all of
these things that I know we all have
various disagreements on why are we all
okay
with that and so many people outside of
this seem to not be okay well I think it
has to do with the fact that most of us
are confident there's a sort of a
principle of faith in rationality that
I'm not that worried about a lot of the
things that the far left is very
concerned about because I have an idea
that more or less if you do the reason
correctly the reason incorrectly
everything is going to work out pretty
much okay and I think that we have the
dexterity in changing our minds
admitting them when we're wrong when
we've changed a perspective and stealing
each other's ideas and and giving credit
so that I have a sense that if I'm you
know Ben and I have not gone toe to toe
on abortion for example and I have an
idea of the outlines of his position he
probably has some idea of mine but my
guess is is that he's not going to go
bananas on spermicide and I'm not going
to be advocating for the right to abort
a child a day before it's due date and
except for extraordinary circumstances
and well and even then I'm not sure but
I think what it is is a certain kind of
confidence that you can allow the other
person in a discussion to actually have
a genuine position and that you can
contend with it and what we need to do
is to push out more of the cognitive
Lego that gives us that confidence to
more people so that they can say I don't
need to fear the disco you know
pro-choice and pro-life or both really
limited positions in my opinion and it's
just an example of one of many things
that we have we have gained the
confidence with each other that we it's
not going to devolve into name-calling
if everybody plays in an honest fashion
and uses the full capacity
that's where it is I mean the honest
fashion things I think what counts I
asked Sam about this earlier says just
doing podcast Sam right because we all
hang out together got really seven
people lunch with his mother was more
important than us but you know what what
I asked him about this and what Sam said
is that he thinks that what what has
changed is that there's there's a bunch
of us who are not interested in the
stupidest version of the argument right
so if if if I want to hear an a a
pro-choice argument I want to hear the
most sophisticated version of the
pro-choice argument then see if I make
an argument against that I don't want
the simplistic version of the pro-choice
argument just so I can knock down the
simplistic version of the pro-choice yes
it makes for a great Ben Shapiro
destroys video but it's more fun for me
like personally I really much more enjoy
engaging with the best ideas that
somebody else has to offer then engaging
with the the worst ideas that you can
pick out of a hand what's really well so
I mean one of the things that was useful
for me for example in this portrayed
discussion with Sam is that my arguments
my arguments are better now than they
were and you might say well why do you
care if your arguments are better and
the reason I care about whether my
arguments are better is because I know
that my arguments are part of the
toolkit that I use to operate
effectively in the world like arguments
aren't just some abstraction that you
hold that's disconnected from your
actions in the world and if my arguments
are more fine-tuned and sharper and if I
am able to and to account for a wider
range of phenomena because someone has
put forward facts that were hard for me
to incorporate then my toolbox is much
more efficient and I can operate more
effectively in the world so I find it
well it's a it's a variant of your
position it's like I want to hear the
best versions of the arguments that run
counter to mine because I'd like to
figure out where I'm wrong and I'd like
to make what I'm doing better and that's
more important to me it is literally
more important to me than making sure
that what I already know is right like
I'm confident in what I know but I also
know that I could do a better job of
expressing it that it could be it could
be the system could be more dynamic it
could take more think more things into
account like I've got plenty to learn
and a real discussion with someone who
objects to you that's where you learn so
so I think apparently I would say that I
think there's pretty easy test which is
when someone catches you out on a part
of the argument that you've made that
you that you know was flawed and someone
catches you out do you smile or you get
angry right thing it really is almost
that easy because the truth is that
there is something fun about the idea of
having to rethink your position and
something adventurous about the idea
that you haven't thought everything
through that there are these new vistas
of thought that maybe you haven't
considered before and it does hone you
it makes you better at it and it also
allows you to listen life is funny and
it's funny that we're flawed human
beings that our logic is flawed so
there's certain humors the idea that
somebody is exposing a rift in your
thinking that you now have to deal with
it's well we like fun if you if you were
just a stone all the time it would be
really boring we kind of got there cuz
when we did the abortion discussion my
position basically I think is similar to
yours which is that at 20 weeks where
they've shown that the fetus can feel
pain that to me is the cutoff I describe
myself as grudgingly pro-choice but you
said to me well if you're acknowledging
that it's a life at 20 well then it's
obviously in a life at 18 now to be
completely cogent in my argument I have
to concede that point to you it didn't
it didn't move me to tell you that I'm
gonna now agree with you on this on what
the policy should be but we can do that
and we didn't punch each other after and
and it's alright it wouldn't you know
and then what if somebody comes in and
says well you know life or not life is a
boolean and the problem is in computer
science is one of casting which is if
you if you make it afloat and you're
talking about the degree of life or the
meaning of the life or the quality of
the life does that change things and so
you know this idea about may I break
your frame well I'd prefer if we stayed
in it for a little while but then let's
explore that in a second and so there's
sort of a generosity of spirit argument
and I think that quite frankly one of
the strangest things about this group of
people is that I find it spectacularly
non-ego ik in terms of when we have a
dinner I don't have a sense that anybody
needs to lead I mean it's as close as
I've seen like a round table where the
sheer pleasure of talking to people at a
time in a time this is a McCarthy like
time
and we have I feel so happy to be at a
table in which I can talk about things
that are troubling me or bring out
something I worry that says something
negative about myself that I'm having
these thoughts that nobody wants to be
booted out of the group by virtue of
grandstanding and I think that that that
kind of it's really interesting watching
people who would be thought of as being
highly ago.if behaving in an ongoing
fashion it's all I think that part of
that too is one of the things Dave and I
have talked about and the technology is
enabling this is that because I've
looked at this group and thought well
why in the world did it ever get
categorized as a group because it's a
strange group and there's some there's
some reasons pretty much everybody who's
in it is entrepreneurial in the
fundamental sense and that everybody's
created their own little domain and it's
kind of hard to knock them over because
they're in their domain so we're not
reliant in some important sense on
external funding let's say to to to to
enable us to continue so that gives us a
certain amount of freedom but another
part of it is that as far as I can tell
everybody who's participated believes
that their audience is intelligent and I
think that that's also a reflection of
that it's it's it's not lack of
intellectual self-confidence it is lack
of commitment to your set of ideas as
long as if they're axiomatically true
but that spills over to the attitude
towards the audience like I don't feel
that I'm there to tell my audience a
bunch of things that they need to know
that I already know when I'm conducting
my tour it's like well here's a bunch of
ideas that I'm confused about still and
I'm going to use this as an opportunity
to explore them and I'm gonna explore
them with you and you guys are going to
come along for the ride and that's going
to be good for everyone I really saw
that with Harris in Vancouver because we
had a well as high level of an
intellectual discussion as we could
manage and I would say it was
approximately at the same level as a
good PhD defense when when the defense
is going well and the audience was with
us the whole way and they're
participating in this discourse process
far more important to participate in the
process of discourse than to specify the
outcome and the audience had made that
decision and abided by it while we were
while we were doing this I think that
that's that is the difference between
yeah I think that's why like Joe Rogan
for exam
it's so popular when I listen to Joe I
know he's going on an intellectual
journey that's going to take three hours
I don't know where the destination is
gonna hurry but I know the returnees
gonna be a lot of fun yeah but I think
that that's that's what makes for
success in this in this field and so
much of our politics so much of our
intellectual life has become what you're
talking about standing on a stage and
people yelling at you what you ought to
think if you're a good person
it's no fun Joe does the same thing that
great authors do it's like a distinction
between Dostoevsky inane Rand it's like
you know we're round is going to end
right from the beginning whereas if you
read a dusty esky novel you have no damn
idea where that's going to come out and
neither did he so he was exploring the
ideas and formulating them as he went
along
and that's true art and now that is what
Rogen does is that you know and and he's
very good at that because he's a smart
guy who isn't afraid of the fact that
there's a whole bunch of things he
doesn't know and so he can lead people
on that journey and the journey is more
important than to use a terrible cliche
the journey is more important than the
destination
I think Maria's a tiny time we have to
get on to other points but the one thing
I would add which is a dangerous idea is
that I think there is a concept of good
diversity and bad diversity which is not
understood in the general population
good diversity is when you have a
collection of people with different
ideas and they're somehow complementing
each other and checking each other and
people are backing down and seeing
things that they wouldn't have seen
because you're walking around the
elephant from all the different sides
and seeing all the different components
bad diversity is something like two
people grow up in different countries
one one drives on the left side of the
road one drives on the right side of the
road and the idea that you decide that
everybody should be able to drive on the
same side of the road that they grew up
on and so instead of everybody getting
to a really interesting panel you've got
a lot of auto accidents and nothing
really interesting happens and so I
think it's very important to be honest
that there is a lack of diversity about
what constitutes conversation and I
think that that's a very troubling thing
because we there's no precedent for
discussing bad diversity at the moment
which is I would much rather listen to
to theologians talking and building up
some high structure and to
atheist astrophysicists talking about
the same thing than having two
conversations of an atheist and an
astrophysics where each of them keeps
tearing down each other starting
assumptions and you come back eight
hours later and nothing has been
achieved but does that kind of explain
your success in a way because probably
four years ago when conservatives were
basically only talking to conservatives
the way the left seems to only be
talking to itself these days you started
doing a little of this and I would
venture to guess that you probably in a
way feel more comfortable with this crew
who you disagree with on a gajillion
things then probably when you're hanging
out with just a bunch of conservatives
that you're like yeah we all agree on
this stuff my name is you know I think
that the the idea that I the fun
conversations are the ones where you're
surprised and I think we have yet to
have a group conversation or even a
conversation one-on-one because we all
talk you know one-on-one to each other
to wear something surprising doesn't get
said and that makes everything a lot
more interesting and fun too right now I
gotta say everything is so boring like
for all the chaos everything is so
boring because it just it breaks down
into a truly you mail order it really it
really is just everybody feels like
everything is spun out of control but
everybody's hunkered down in their own
bunker and so everything comes down to
Trump is always right or Trump is always
wrong and we're all supposed to revolve
around this this black hole that is
Trump or this Sun that is Trump and he's
the center of gravity I don't think most
people live their lives thinking about
these problems the whole Trump attack
and Trump defense thing is really dull I
mean when I went on Mars show there was
the YouTube part afterwards and the
panelists with the exception of me were
tearing Trump apart and I was sort of
watching that from the outside in some
sense partly because I'm in Canadian and
I thought well first of all it's just
not that interesting that you can list
Trump's faults it's like you and you and
my crazy neighbor it's like why you're
not bringing anything to the table doing
that it's too easy and then of course
the other problem is while by going
after Trump you're going after his
supporters hypothetically speaking and
of course that's 50% of your population
which turns out to be a very big
strategic problem for you you know now
and in the future so it is dull and and
and I don't I don't think people are
people would rather have a
a more interesting conversation that's
what we can offer to Sonu so that's what
I want where I wanted to take this how
do we I mean we we hit on this a little
bit in the first two hours but how do we
do that now how do we lay I think we're
already laying out a more interesting
conversation but how do we also lay out
something that doesn't make everyone
feel horrible because that is a lot of
what's going on here all these people
that are showing up to your events
they're going wow what a reprieve I mean
I haven't been able to do that
politically I wouldn't say I mean what
I've been suggesting to people is that
as intolerable as they find their lives
for reasons that are arbitrary and
self-inflicted there are things that
they could do at the individual level
that will make a radical improvement
they're difficult things there are
things that require the adoption of
responsibility and vision and the
willingness to to speak your partial and
imperfect truth but if you put that into
practice there is an OP now one of the
things that needs to be done in the
political sphere is to delineate what
that up might look like politically you
know to give people something that's
positive to strive for it well I
mentioned earlier that I see that to
some degree in the burgeoning literature
that's suggesting that many things
around the world are improving very
rapidly you know in your counter
position was well that doesn't mean our
situation isn't fragile which I also
agree with what but there is reason I
think there is genuine reason to be
optimistic about the future at a
sociological and political level and I
think that that's something that we
could be having a more serious
discussion about so I think yeah I think
that's right I also think that you know
what the reason that you've been so
successful is because while you are
speaking in in kind of terms about
society everyone reads it as self-help
and everybody reads it as self-help and
I think that pretty much all of us what
we are saying is being read as self-help
and I think that that's empowering
because basically we're saying to people
is for the most part it's a free country
like shut up and get on with your life
yeah just it's not like there's a bumper
sticker that is going around you know
that the Shapiro 2020 or 2024 bumper
stickers with the something I said on
the show which would solve your own
problems right which is ooh because
we're all looking for the banners all
better on ones better than that it
doesn't solve your own problems it's
three three
solve your own problems you can solve
your own problems and you'll find the
deepest meaning in your life if you
decide that you're going to solve your
own exactly now that's a nice
combination I think that message is is
for the vast Malay even when you're
talking about societal problems the very
emphasis on reason is a suggestion that
you can solve a lot of the problems in
your life if you change how you're
thinking I think we are engaged in a
collective form of cognitive behavioral
therapy I think that everybody is
depressed and we don't know why we're
depressed and we're upset and we don't
really know why we're upset I was saying
my wife the other day like if you a
couple of things so I say my wife the
other day if you were in 1913 these so
we just dropped you in 2018
you think my god this is heaven my kids
are dying and in youth my wife's I'm
gonna die in childbirth I'm not gonna
really have to experience dire poverty I
can get anything I want from the comfort
of my own home and go anywhere everybody
has several cars
I have entertainment that never ends
right all of this stuff is just
fantastic and then yesterday I was
having I was having lunch with a
prominent Hollywood figure of his name I
won't mention so he doesn't lose work
and we're doing it at a restaurant in
Brentwood and we were talking about
Trump and politics and I was looking
around this room and everybody's
drinking $200 bottles of Chardonnay and
then they're in the bubbly water and
then and they've got their their kale
salad and the whole thing and it
occurred to me that 98 percent of the
people in this room think we are living
in danger of incipient fascism right if
you would pull the room and say are we
living in crisis mode 98% of people that
room go yes we're living in crisis while
they sip their Chardonnay I thought well
then either you're not active enough or
you're just lying yourselves because you
don't actually think that we're in
crisis now that's not to say that we we
aren't at crisis point because there's
so many people willing to break the
system but I think that one of the
things that's coming true right now is
that so many people think that the
system is irrevocably broken that they
are willing to break the system that was
what Maher said essentially bring on the
recession because that'll rid us of
Trump it's like well you want the
disease so that you can have the cure
it's like it's not helpful yeah where I
should sit this one out so I sort of
radically disagree I think that a lot of
the people who are at the very top
understand why these games are fragile
and so the games are still serviceable
but if you actually understand how the
games are played you understand
and just how quickly this thing could
turn so I think first of all it is
precisely the people with enough success
because it shouldn't mean they would be
willing to turn it that's the thing
well that's where I don't get the
distinction the number of people with
nine and ten figures worth of wealth
talked to me about like the rich and the
powerful as if they are some different
group yes it's very hot and rich is
richer than me that's what I think it's
that there's a difference between people
who have their Senators on speed dial
and people who don't so you know the
rich is not a monolith and that's one of
the huge problems in this story if
you're engaged in some kind of business
like armament or extraction where you
need to have a very close relationship
with government you see the world very
differently than if you're very good at
picking investment opportunities and you
just want to be unfettered in your
ability to go to go make more you know I
think that one of the things that really
resonates about your message and and I
feel a little bit less close to Ben on
is is that somehow the message that you
should improve your own life got
conflated with if your own life isn't
awesome it's because you failed to make
it so and I think that was it sort of
more true in a period of uniform high
growth as between 1945 and 1970 when you
know if you had beta to the system if
you just had exposure hard work usually
paid off I think the depending upon what
sector you're in what your skillset is
where you are in your life it's very
hard for some people to turn things
around and the idea of look you may not
be able to solve your problem you solve
the problems you confront but you can
solve the portion of the problems that
you can solve yourself and that you
should at least do that that is a very
different message because it says even
if I'm not living in luxury at the end
of it it's not because I failed and I
think the decoupling or distinction and
I would probably you know given that
criticism I probably agree to the
curbing of my own kind of solution right
like I think that I think that's right
clearly there are people we are all
created equal in our rights we're not
all created equal in our abilities or in
our capacity to rise or fall in this
or in trade for 100% and I would do the
other half of that thing which is I
would climb down from asking you know if
more people were willing to admit that I
would say okay it's very important that
people at least make an a co-payment of
trying to solve the problems in their
own life before demanding that the
outside that's the part and that's the
part that I focus on more simply because
I think that the government is so big I
mean there's more politics and
philosophy made right so I think the
government is so big and so intrusive
and so involved in so many areas of our
life that the the tendency right now in
America is to blame other people for the
problems that you have and that's true
on virtually every side of the aisle I
think that when you and I have
disagreements about trade theory but I
think when President Trump goes to a
Rust Belt town in Ohio and he says I'm
gonna bring back all your jobs because
the Mexicans and the Chinese screwed you
I think that that's that's a lie I don't
think he's bringing back those jobs
aren't disagreeing about them yeah and
so and so you know I think that when my
solution to that is there's not
necessarily a solution I think one of
the lies that there's always a solution
to every problem that can be had if you
just have enough communal power behind
him and I don't think that's right I
think that the solution for most
problems in life not all because I don't
think all problems in life ever again
solved but at least the majority of the
major mistakes people make in their life
that create obstacles that they can
never overcome the rest of their life
are self-inflicted I think that the the
the unbarring health serious health
problems or mental disability and I
think that the number of problems that
make it impossible for you to overcome
sheer dire poverty in the United States
virtually all of those problems are
problems that people put in front of
themselves and so if you can make those
basic decisions they can turn your life
around in a pretty significant way yeah
or you if they're not problems that
people create for themselves there are
problems that are they're subject to
that are also very intractable to
communal level solutions like mental
illness is a good example of that and
its contribution to homelessness it's
like well it's terrible to be mentally
ill and to end up on the streets it
definitely is terrible but it isn't like
we actually know how to solve that so
even if that can't be put at the feet of
the individuals who are suffering it's
like okay well we'd like to sort that
out communally it's hard to sort that
out without making it worse we don't
know do you guys think we can only make
it a little better or
a little worse like of course all hell
could break loose on one side of it but
that within the margins like it's pretty
good and we can maybe make it a little
better but that that the capacity for
humans to make a system much better than
this that will allow most noble to
flourish worse like that's what I'm yeah
we can aim for incremental improvement
which compounds by the way so that
that's very powerful incremental
improvement but we could aim for
incremental improvement while deciding
that we're going to stay off stave off
chaotic and unnecessary descents into
the abyss right which is what I see the
danger in this in this polarization
processes not generating it's like a
catastrophe that we actually don't need
what would he make of the amount of
people that seem to want that right now
I mean I always say every week on the
show it's like Twitter is not real life
yeah but the amount of people that I'm
seeing constantly talking about tear it
down and now the new attack on civility
where even if you say be civil
be respectful that that is now thought
of as a tool of the patriarchy or
a tool the oppressed or all of that
stuff what do you make of that assault I
mean I think first of all the
fundamental hatred of the system by a
lot of people is I'm not gonna justify
it given the fact that the system that
we have is the best that has ever you
know happened to any human beings in the
history of the world I mean this is a
pretty great place to live
compared to all other right cuz right
nothing compared to utopia compared to
heaven I'm not saying can't get any
better I think that one of the great
dangers always is utopianism and I think
you're seeing it from both sides I mean
right now when you saw Alexandra Ocasio
Sanchez when in New York and she's
promising universal health care
universal college tuition Universal
Universal housing right all of this
stuff is gonna magically happen then
she's asked on MSNBC are gonna pay for
any of this and she just basically says
well just how FDR did after didn't okay
one of the big problems yeah and the and
also there was a giant world war
happening at the time so it's the the
the itch to to grow to provide that
that's the thing it's like that's you
you really you really want to you want
to make a state that has enough power to
grant all those wishes it's like careful
what kind of genie you generate because
it's going to have a demand on you so I
don't think the market is that the free
markets are inherently utopia and I
don't think that a vast government is
inherently
but I think free markets at least have a
certain respect for human labour dignity
and individuality and collectivist
utopia is certainly do not and they also
have a certain distributed quality it's
like it's not like there's a central
administration making the decisions so
even if the decisions are bad which
sometimes they are they tend to be
self-correcting and mostly they operate
locally so there's something to be said
for that so what do you say to all the
people that are gonna listen to this
that I think you're a little more
sympathetic to the rest of us that are
going but but we need help or or this is
this sounds cold or my lord is gonna be
colder than this you guys are like
warming my heart with their bootstraps I
mean there was a phase change in the
economy around 1970 that I cannot get
people to focus on and you know if you
look at like GDP which is a very flawed
measure and median male income which
Tyler Cowen I think was the one who
pointed out that this is the best
version of the argument one of these
things they're they're both going up
together until like 1970 yeah and then
one of them flatlined and then keeps
going and the idea that this is not a
structural change that is in every
school textbook and that we don't
understand that we've built up to plus
generations of experts lying about what
happened what do you what do you think
happened what do you I did that B
because I've read criticisms of the
decoupling theories nobody likes my
version of it but no because I don't
understand it everyone who cares about
this stuff should read a guy named Eric
de sola Price who was active in the late
50s and started talking about there will
be a singularity in science so he looked
at prices law yeah number of PhDs number
of journals number amount of funding
everything was going up exponentially
and things that go up exponentially
cannot continue and so he predicted this
is going to end because there would be
too many PhD you know too many PhDs per
child and sure enough that system sort
of came apart so if you look at the
period from between 1945 to 1970 you
have this growth regime and everything
that got built during that time has what
I call an ego an embedded growth
obligation if it doesn't grow at this
rate it's going to turn pathological and
so we built a ton of infrastructure
around this beautiful period of high
broadly distributed fairly even in
stable technology technologically life
growth and that ended and then began
this crazy period of excuse making where
we found every gimmick known demand and
if you want to read an article about
this call I think I wrote one called
anthropic capitalism in the new gimmick
economy and so part of the problem is is
that the concept of jobs as how we feed
ourselves rather than creative
enterprises or something else jobs are
probably tied to a period of time that
isn't going to go on forever and it's
probably weakening as a means of feeding
us so the market was unbelievably
brilliant and then there was a
structural change and now the question
is how do we account for these egos that
make embedded growth obligations that
make Liars of all of the experts who
service the institutions so the big
problem that we're having the reason we
can't wake up from this madness is is
that you've had since about 1970 people
having to lie to keep the institutions
afloat so what's the lie well take a law
firm the idea is you have some number of
partners the partners have associates
all the associates want to become
partners so you have to tell them a
story about if you work hard you will
become partners but when you hit
steady-state like the professors the
professor wants to have 20 students the
20 students want to become professors to
have 20 students none of this stuff
works anymore but the intimate love your
thing it's it's a hidden what do you
call that game it's a hidden pyramid
scheme pyramid scheme come ability
levels since 1980 have been relatively
stable in the United States well we've
been a very rich family trying to figure
out ways to live out our days in the
style to which we become accustomed and
we found every kind of gimmick known to
man whether it's offshoring or you know
mergers and acquisitions or you know
self regulation of markets all of these
things that we've learned how they were
just the transfer over to the service
economy as opposed to in the
intellectual economy as opposed to
manufacturing well the thing is is that
a lot of this was led by something like
you know science in the form of let's
say just semiconductors coming out of
physics you know how much of
of our current growth has been
scientifically led and now you know with
Moore's law the reason everybody talks
about it is it's one of these growth
laws that can't go on forever so I'm
doing pretty well I mean part of it I
know things that are impossible can't
continue forever that's the rule listen
the doubling seems to be one of them the
ideas that we've been pretty good
staving off disaster for a very long
time it seems to me though that there is
like this is and this is this is perhaps
part of the contradiction that people
are wrestling with is like and you're
pointed to two structural deception
let's say something like that and
delusion the delusions that go along
with it but it also does seem to me and
this is where the measurement issues
become so complicated is that even
though wages among men have been flat
since the 1970s I think you could make a
pretty cogent case that we are actually
in many ways much richer than we were
first of all the world's much richer
there's much less poverty worldwide and
in an absolute sense as well and so even
if the average American isn't richer
let's say although we could dispute that
the world that surrounds him is much
richer and that actually constitutes a
form of accrued wealth because you're
actually safer when when a quarter of
the Chinese aren't starving and a
quarter of the Indians are okay so but
so but then I would also say so there
although there's been local stagnation
in the West arguably there's been
massive global in improvements and but
then the other question is is the idea
of local stagnation actually accurate
because there are lots of ways that we
are clearly way richer than we were now
we're certainly richer in terms of our
access to high-quality information at a
very very low cost and so the
technological revolution seems to be
real and we can purchase a lot more of
this high-quality technology for less
money than we could so I'm not I'm not
entirely convinced of the wage state
about the wage stagnation argument
there's a tremendous amount to be done
but the metrics about how we measure
yeah things there's also a total flaw
that is suffused throughout economics I
just came back from four days in Venice
and the first day in Venice I thought
this place is unreal if the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen in my
higher life every 52 years didn't
prepare me right great more days later I
was like wow there's so many tourists
and okay took almost no time to remove
that level of magic because I got used
to it that quickly yeah yeah yeah well
that's a problem we get we get use of
the headaches that are going well
extraordinary atomically numbing is a
real issue
the other thing is is that what were the
Gini coefficients measuring the
inequality during the period that was
going up you know we're now in a period
of such inequality that you know humans
are very focused on things like status
yes yes yes and so it's not clear to me
that people wouldn't be actually happier
in a totally different regime I mean we
have enough companies that wouldn't
exactly right yeah now in all of it all
of that might Michael that okay so
that's that's an interesting issue
because one of the things we could say
perhaps is that between 1945 and 1972
what was provided for people wasn't so
much a standard of living that's higher
than we have now but a trajectory of
development that appeared more stable
stable and believable and so a low
variance yeah yes well so so and then
the question is well what actually do
you want do you want a high standard of
living or do you want to believe that if
you put an incremental effort your life
can improve and it could easily be that
people will rather have the ability to
make a 30 year plan we want the ability
yes yes if what I value right minister
to your plan and I want to have some
idea of how I'm gonna get to my
retirement and put kids through school
and do all of this it's this plan yeah
idea the predictability is gone no
question right that's why I said jobs
are not going to be the means of
redistribution well right I do wonder if
you know on the individual level I think
that yeah that's you're right there's
there's an enormous amount of chaos and
volatility in the system and but I I
think that the only thing that you can
say to that is the same thing that
that's been true for most of human
history okay the time when people could
actually stabili predict that in 30
years I will be significantly better off
than I am now and I can make a
retirement plan that's about 50 years of
human history I mean before that it was
basically you have
kids one of them dies and then your wife
dials in childbirth but birth the second
to you you have eight then you have
eight and six of them die three or
miscarriages and fine yeah you know then
and so that so this this dream that we
had right in 1914 1970 even if I loved
the premises I'm not sure that that's a
realistic dream about what that was my
point is it yeah so that was the
entropic capitalism you just ascribed it
to not under your article but the only
one I'm making is that I think that what
really has been lost and this is the
part that I'm really focusing on a lot
lately is we can't control the situation
around us but we can't control our
reactions to the situation and what I
mean by that is these massive systemic
changes that we're talking about we
number one don't agree on what those
systemic changes should be right and
number or even what they are right what
they are or what they would do right
nobody knows what the hell thing we do
and with all of that said the one thing
that you can control is the amount of
virtue that you yourself pour into your
life and it seems to me in a non
virtuous position that because somebody
else is earning more than you you are
therefore worse off and so what we
really have lost I think and this may be
an outgrowth I mean that there's there's
not even may I know general Gober makes
this argument for example that that sort
of late-stage capitalism or advanced
capitalism tends to tends to lead to
this rat race where we are looking what
the guy next door to us has but the but
the lack of just basic virtue in the
position that I am more soft because my
neighbor is better off even though I
have more stuff than I did five years
ago
the lack of inculcation of any sense of
what I would call basic morality is
having a significant impact well one is
that one of the things that's happening
clearly in in the tour that I'm doing in
the people that I'm talking to is I'm
actually making a variant of that case I
said that and and it's it's probably in
keeping with your vision as well so
let's imagine that a rising tide does
lift all boats and that's actually
happening but we're purchasing up that
at the price of a certain degree of
predictability and stability into the
future that seems quite clear and that's
exaggerated by this incredibly rapid
rate of technological change it's like
okay so how do we tolerate all that
uncertainty given that we're also
deriving substantial benefit from it we
don't want to we don't want to mess it
up
and what I've been suggesting to my
audiences is get your act together as
much as you possibly can because the way
that you deal with uncertainty is by
being prepared for anything and
everything that's going to come your way
and so you want to put yourself together
so that when the difficult decisions
come along even though we can't predict
what they are you're going to be in the
best possibility message here the new
message is that whatever like I want to
tell somebody you know very often I hear
parents like we have two children and
one of them is living at home and I say
okay let me explain in part why your
child may be living at home when you're
disappointed that that's happening right
and so I go through the economics argue
person who feels better oh wow or I
explain you know here's why you're not
able to catch up to your parents it's
not all about your personal failure
right and so the idea that that personal
responsibility is something that we need
and we also can't have right it's too
dangerous you have to do this tailored
message and I think you've been into
itting this like here's the portion of
your life that you're responsible for
and we're going to delineate it and if
your room isn't cleaned up it's not
because of the government right that was
your point saying and and this is you
know again you and I are gonna have to
do this at some point this is a great
country and well if you put your mind to
making money then it may be the case
that stick-to-itiveness and passing the
marshmallow test and being inventive and
creative works but there are a lot of
people who are given a very different
message and they grow up being told you
know be a good person and work hard and
a lot of this stuff doesn't work the way
it used to it just doesn't and lying
about it offends me so I want to say
look if making money is very important
and we need to be able to talk about the
role of money it's money as fungible
everything else is not so if you make
money then you have lots and lots of
options and we need to give people the
idea that that's a good thing to pursue
if they have any hope and in dream but
it's also the case that fundamentally
what we what your message is is you have
to make the copay and the copay is the
part of your life that you absolutely
control and if that's out of control
don't expect anyone else to take any
simple then you can also make if that
part of your life is in order you can
also make a more credible argument for
the existence
of unreasonable systemic impediments
because you can say to yourself look I
put everything in today then you could
make a credit business why this is the
the attractive version of the personal
responsibility thing that the point we
have it we have another problem here
with our discussion about dispossession
because like one of the things that
that's bothered me about the left and
the right is the right tends to think
well if you just got your act together
and worked hard you can make it and that
and the and the the left tends to think
well everybody's the same and if you
removed systemic impediment that
everybody could could do whatever they
needed to do well the left is wrong
because there's real diversity of
ability but the right is wrong because
there's a real diversity of ability and
so for example there is a distribution
of IQ which is real and if you're if
you're the the psychometric data
basically indicate that if you have an
IQ of less than 90 which is about
fifteen twenty percent of the population
you actually can't read well enough to
follow instructions and you might say
well that can be rectified say through
educational means and so forth and the
evidence for that is pretty damn thin
and so the problem with a society that's
meritocratic fundamentally even if it's
meritocratic based on character is that
they're still going to be individual
differences that seem to be an eight
that are going to produce radically
unequal outcomes many of which are
payable but the thing that you will have
a hard time convincing me of having gone
through the PhD system in the sciences
is that some of the world's most
brilliant people hold PhDs in the
sciences and I came up at a time when in
the early 90s these people we're told
that the world was their oyster and that
we were desperately in need of
scientists and I remember a friend of
mine being told that he had a $14,000 a
year job offer post PhD from MIT with a
pregnant wife and the person who offered
it was like this is great we can we can
we can get people for pennies right and
why was that it was because of something
that came out of the National Academy of
Sciences and the National set of Science
Foundation to slam American workers in
the sector this is very very important
it had predicted that people would be
paid six figures for PhDs
which was you know larger than they had
been paid for a long time and it was the
meddling with the marker the thing that
I don't like about the personal
responsibility issue is is that
individuals should not be solving the
problems of let's say tech groups
getting together and say we will not
poach each other's employees that like
the market has to work for people not
just institutions and if you're in a
sector in which you can make the market
work for you you have this feeling of
anybody can do this and in fact what you
need to do is you need to migrate to
these sectors because there are other
sectors where you have let's say
government intervention which says we
are going to interfere with the free
working of the market or we are not
going to take into account that some
people produce public goods and so it's
very important to me to understand that
some people are coming out of very
different circumstances in which it's
very unlikely that they will be able to
make their world you know grow and
blossom and that other people of
extraordinary ability and high IQ and
work ethic find themselves not fighting
forces that they don't even know this is
the sort of criticism that's often
levied at me because people say well you
don't take the systemic problem
sufficiently into account and and so
that's a nice outline of the systemic
you know when when the bank's decided
that they should be self-regulating with
respect you know - they're gearing
ratios or the risk there was one guy who
rode in at this - this SEC hearing to
allow these investment banks to you know
do the last little bit before 2008 blew
up everything this guy Len Bolle who was
a computer consultant to banks it's like
one guy in the entire country who saw a
disaster coming and got involved in this
internal game that was a by banks for
banks and so what's very important to me
is to understand when you have bad
behavior by institutions it is
pathological to put that responsibility
on individual shoulders well but the
only coda I would make to that and I
think that's a fair comment is that what
I'm hoping and what I'm trying to
convince people of is that their ethical
responsibility which is partly to
further their own development to the
degree that they can does extend to the
community is that you want to make
ethical said
so that they don't make mistakes that
corrupt the operation of the system at a
systemic level the best way to do that
in my estimation over the long run is to
concentrate on the ethical behavior of
the sovereign citizen now that doesn't
address this problem and place the
systems systems affect more people that
means that when people make vague
accusations about systems that are
dysfunctional
then it's not helpful you know what I
see is not you're making very specific
very specific institutions in very
specific ways and those that's useful
because then we can actually have a
discussion about where those systems go
wrong so you can have it as a unit you
know it's got your housing the
patriarchy right you can we can just
know I'm trying to I'm trying to crowd
that out and part of it yes what it is
is that almost nobody in the regular
commentariat wants to talk to me about
what went wrong with our immigration
policy how did we get in trouble with
mortgage-backed securities what's going
on with CPI adjustment because
unfortunately we got something better
going on here so let's not worry about
them but you know we only have about 10
minutes because you got a hard out so I
thought we'd do a little self therapy
while we're here so I want to ask you
each one thing I'll even answer it
myself and then we can all sort of
comment I'll start there if you had one
blind spot what do you think it might be
I've asked you guys some version of all
of this before but you know a lot of
changes over the time that we keep doing
this but if there was something that you
thought was your personal blind spot
what would it be
well I would say I don't know if I can
identify a specific blind spot but I
could say in general you know I know
perfectly well that I don't know enough
about a lot of the things that I need to
know about to make the sorts of
arguments that I'm making like I'm
painfully aware and increasingly aware I
would say of just how much I don't know
how much more I need to be reading and
concentrating on to flesh out what I
have to say like that I don't know I
don't know enough about economics barely
anything I don't know a lot about
history barely anything and so I'm more
and more aware of how much I don't know
and now I don't know if that's the kind
of blind spot that you were thinking of
but but but it it it's terrifying to
comprehend that and still try to move
forward in this sort
space it makes it tough to be a public
person these days right because everyone
wants you to know everything about
everything all the problem that Derek
was just describing which is you know
the reason that people won't contend
with you is because you force them to
move from their low resolution
ideological certainties into domains
where specific knowledge is necessary
you instantly expose everyone's
ignorance it's like that's that's hard
on the people that you're having the
discussion with but the devil is in the
details
all till the last sentence I would say
that I would love you to shorten that
and put it on a bumper sticker for me it
was a brilliant summary yeah blindspot
Shapiro I mean I find it hard to argue
with with any of that I think that you
know if you're intellectually curious
then that means that you know that you
don't know anything so I agree with with
everything he just said I mean as far as
other intellectual blind spots I mean or
other blind spots generally I would say
that for me the constant struggle is I
find myself more stressed out now than I
was two years ago when no one gave a
crap when I thought right so so the fact
is that it's you know living a less
stressful life in the middle of
believing that people actually care what
you think it means you have to take your
stuff much more seriously that's
something that really a blind spot as
much as a concern and I think that that
means that you know just that the
commitment to to hearing more about
things as is deeply necessary but it
also means that it just means your life
in many ways is more miserable more
people know about you and it's not a
poor me thing I love what I do I love
the fact that people care what I think
like that's really I mean it's it's
pretty sweet you got a lot of good stuff
great stuff going on but the fact is
that I suppose I spend I mean the risk
is higher in some ways that makes you a
better person it's almost like the you
know the the old kind of religious
slogan that if you feel God is watching
you all the time then you're more likely
to be a better person
and there is that feeling like okay if I
make a mistake I'd want to be the first
person to notice that I made the mistake
and correct that mistake but that also
means that you live with a lot more
self-doubt and a lot more
second-guessing of yourself and you did
you know when nobody cared so it's so
that's not as much of a blind spot as
concern but the problem with trying to
identify your own blind spots is that
they're in your blind spot but it's
that's why I asked the question I wanted
to make it pick a little bit it's funny
cuz
the other day or was yesterday actually
I did the Adam Carolla podcast which
he's you know it's comedy and he's doing
more of a radio show thing so you speak
a little more freely and I was about to
say something very politically incorrect
and I obviously don't have a problem
doing that generally especially when I'm
doing comedy and just for a moment I had
you sort of ring in my head about be
careful about your words and I was like
I just don't feel like offering up one
extra con that way right because like
the stuff that you felt like you could
say you're now you realize not only
maybe you shouldn't have said it a year
ago but also you feel like if I if am i
you're constantly saying am i curbing
myself because I'm afraid or my crimping
myself because it's the right thing to
do to curb myself here mm-hmm and then
so that's an interesting sort of
calculus you have to do all the time
yeah if you're concerned that it's
because of fear then you might want to
take the risk of saying it you know
because I've tried wrestled with that
problem is like you know or maybe am i
avoiding this because I think it's
better because I don't want to take on
the responsibility if you have
suspicions about that then you should do
it because I think you should I should
think you should arm yourself against
your weaknesses and take that risk
I think it's better developmentally to
do that all right I'll answer or answer
it for myself which is a cue of
something your brother said to me once
which is that perhaps I have a little
PTSD from the left so my focus on these
completely bananas ideas has been has
been so singularly stuck in my mind that
maybe I let some other things slide
every now and again I'm trying to be
very aware of that and trying to figure
out how to go forward on that so does
that mean you're a little bit more on
the attack then you'd like to be because
I think I want to ease up on a little
bit of the attack on that I think I've
spent the last couple years really it
was first me identifying it for myself
really I was interviewing all of these
people and figuring out that they were
often going through the same thing I was
but then it morphed into going on the
attack about it and now I feel like
because and again I say the word winning
with you know a little tongue-in-cheek
but because I do sense something has
turned here that maybe I can get my foot
off the gas a little bit on the big
ideas that I really care but I thought
about that in relationship to this whole
group it might be nice but I think we
should really be careful to use
necessary force yeah there's there's
idiocy on the left and on the on the
extreme right that needs to be pointed
out but it might be better if we did the
minimum necessary amount of that because
it also starts to become saying
something you can parody quite easily at
some point and more and more of
delineating what the alternative might
be if there was a positive alternative
right it will be interesting to see what
happens with the IDW as it moves beyond
the critique right because the what's
really unified us I think has been a lot
the critique right there antique of
intersectionality in the identity
politics and once we move into the space
we're actually trying to maybe build
something together or come to some sort
of ideological continents then some of
these some of these but I hopefully what
I hope is different if we're gonna pitch
away the arguments I hope that we
recapitulate the arguments and more
reasonable cogent and intelligent way
you know in terms of the actual
political arguments but I'm not sure
that those I think that none of us I
hope our dreaming that there will
actually be an ideological countenance
among a lot of us as clearly that is
something that is not going to happen I
mean we all have significant
disagreements among ourselves on all of
these issues but how beautiful that is
that we're all kind of working through
it in our own way and we're all not
gonna get to the exact same ending but
we'll kind of go with each other all the
time
blindspot feinstein oh my gosh it's more
or less infinite I think that I do a
terrible job of when somebody's making a
bad analytic argument but is intuited
their way to the right conclusion I tend
to discount them as if the analytic
argument was how how they should be
thinking so different kinds of minds who
have their variables you know if you if
you think nothing of myers-briggs it
should at least tell you that there are
kinds of minds that aren't working at
all like yours big five might be a
little bit better so that's been a huge
blind spot I think that I am very
focused on provable institutional
betrayal which I can point at and no one
else seems to want to talk about and
that because no one wants to talk about
really specific problems with the
institution's it leads me sometimes to
not seeing the generic case I
think that I am very much a prisoner of
my learning disabilities I had to sort
of construct my own operating system to
get around them otherwise if you ever
want to see something funny ask Brett
Weinstein to read aloud because you
could you just see that he's having to
impression istic we figure out what's on
the page because he's not tracking it
exactly so I think that you know that
fight to say I'm not stupid
probably distorted me a great deal on
having to build my own architecture and
I think I think we can safely say you're
not stupid so I think one last thing and
I think that one of the things that I'm
most worried about is that fighting the
supposedly empathic army of people
trying to destroy conversation itself
has had a very negative impact on my
empathy for exactly the people that they
want me to have empathy for and I think
that it's very important for all of us
to say okay what's the steal Manning of
that position and to make an extra
effort when people are making absolutely
non empathic arguments trying to destroy
you and fry you to think about the
empathy that you want to have for
whatever went wrong in my life it might
be fun at some point to conjure up a
panel where some of the people that are
in this group take the leftist position
and defend it in in every possible way
you know right from the post-modern
conclusions which you know I think are
worthy of substantial skepticism to the
to the notion of the reality of the
dispossessed and they and the presence
of systemic oppression and all of that
and to and to make the cases as as
brutally as we possibly can with a
useful not Steele man those tactics yeah
the tactics to come with him because
then we could because it doesn't seem
like we've been able to have the debate
with anybody who can carry the debate so
it might be really you I think Ted and I
have been trying but it's it's it's hard
because we're spending most of our
energy fending off I think we've all
been tact the tactics that's exactly
yeah that's not the conclusions all
right we got to move on Jordan I are
going to Long Beach tonight you're going
to San Francisco you're going
- daily why're you guys are doing
selling for July 4th through July 4th of
July 2nd we're gonna be doing a special
episode of daily we're backstage that's
me that's a god-king Jeremy boring who
runs the place
it is the execrable michael Knowles and
Andrew Clavin and Jordan Peterson we're
all going to be celebrating 4th of July
with everyone's favorite Canadian so
Jordans gonna stop by at 4 p.m. Pacific
7 p.m. Eastern so check out daily we're
calm for all bad you can check it out at
YouTube and Facebook as well links down
below and see you tonight Long Beach
you